now my understanding is that this was
initially imagined by you
as a pilot for a television series
how
did it change and develop and grow
from that idea to being a feature well i
had to give it an end um so i sent it to
shira piven who directed the movie and
is an old friend and i wanted some
feedback and she said if you rewrite
this as a feature i will make it happen
so i did and yeah it was just about
finding an end to the story that felt
good and
natural and real how far
let's say it was are you saying it was a
thirty minute or sixty it's a thirty
minute yeah i think how far did it go
in the story it ended with the first
moment of the broadcast
so it was hi my name is alice glee
welcome to me then black so it just took
took you to that moment i felt like it
was like a bullet leaving a gun you know
what is she going to do
and you have quite a history with
shirapivan the director she's you have
an acting background so you guys have
worked together in that yeah she's
directed me as an actor and she she's
also an educator she's an amazing improv
teacher she kind of grew up in chicago
theater royalty and has been teaching a
lot and i knew her that way and she
actually got me writing we used to do
like timed writing exercises during
class and that kind of got me going i
love it um you guys got a great review
in the new york times for this film and
three of the
adjectives that were used to describe it
were touching
amusing and disturbing were you going
for all three of those in equal measure
i like those flavors together
the whole thing was sort of about that
moment in life that where you're
laughing and crying at the same time and
you're not sure where to go
and i like those moments where you're
not sure if you're supposed to laugh too
and then sometimes you do and you feel
bad about it and it's like cathartic and
alive
obviously this is a character who
is mentally ill she's she has borderline
personality disorder but i feel like
you're also
talking about
everybody
in in this film you're talking about a
lot of us aren't you hopefully you see
yourself in there i definitely do um but
yeah i feel like
the stuff that alice wants
is stuff that a lot of us want we want
to be seen and heard and some of us want
to be televised and
yeah
did you see an end to that
or is it just going to get worse i mean
it is infuriating to kind of walk
especially when i'm in new york just to
walk around and every you know
everyone's like this or like this and i
swear i have my questions on here which
is why i have my phone with me but i
mean it's it's literally gotten insane
now i don't see an end i think
everybody's going to have their own tv
network not just show
when technology improves and storage
improves i think everybody's going to
have it all i'm waiting for the moment
where someone actually does win the
lotto and then buys themselves a tv
network or a talk show it could really
happen it could really happen
tell me about
bringing kristen wiig on board was she
someone that you had in mind at any
point of writing this or developing it
was she a dream
candidate for you she was always in my
head i kind of didn't dare to dream
though because it seemed like such a
long shot but it happened i mean she was
definitely her combination of pathos and
sort of offbeat humor just seemed
perfect for alice and then when it
happened that was just amazing and then
everybody jumped on
because everybody wants to do a movie
with kristen wick because she's so
beloved so what was the process like of
finding out getting into her finding out
that she was interested did you then
meet with her or did she say yes just on
the printed page
i think she was very interested after
reading the script we did talk about
tone and stuff like that and um we got
it to her manager and waited a good
while for her to read it
and then she uh she said yes
was there a role i mean we were talking
out there in the lobby about just
between jennifer jason lee and james
marsden and wes bentley tim robbins john
q sac loretta devine i mean it's insane
all the people that signed on was there
one part that was
particularly hard to to nail to to get
someone great find that right person no
again it was like kristen wiig in the
script and everybody jumped on which is
just so like thrilling it was throwing i
was on set for most of the shoot and
watching these people that i've admired
like john cusack and jennifer jason lee
it was just absolutely thrilling to
watch them work how would you say your
background in improvisation and in
comedy in general how did that affect
your writing process your writing style
and
what you were able to contribute when
you were on the set i think it made me
very loose and collaborative a lot of
like whenever kristin reads an a
prepared statement which she does quite
a lot
um i usually would just like write those
right before she did them like or have a
few so i was able to kind of roll with
stuff improv is really good for that
improv is really good for writing
for a movie like this where your main
character
does have so many issues and is so out
there in a way
you really do need
characters who are surrogates for the
audience i would imagine my guess is
that the linda cardellini character fits
that bill the most did you have a couple
characters in mind that
were audience representatives in a way
sort of or just people who would sort of
ground the madness but definitely gina
linda cardellini's character was someone
who i think we can relate to in terms if
we've ever had anybody with mental
illness in our lives and so many of us
have we can relate to that sort of
exhaustion
and concern
and i think she brings so much to that
role she's so good
you were saying that this
whole project came out of a a dark place
in in your life i don't know how you
want to go
into that but yeah i used to write with
a partner actually right and perform
with a partner and she died very early
she died when she was 38 years old and i
just went into kind of a couple of year
funk and i did sleep in a sleeping bag
on top of my bed and watched a lot of
infomercials and sort of the grieving
process
kind of made me a writer like i really
before i was sort of half acting half
writing writing stuff that i would
perform but
that process of getting over my friend's
death
kind of made that made me a writer do
you feel her
spirit in this project absolutely all
over it really in what way
well when we when we performed together
we did this very weird show called guile
and we would stand on stage and make
outrageous claims about our life like
stephanie claimed that she was in the
movie jaws and she did that speech about
the shark's black eyes even though she
was a woman it made no sense
we would act out very explicit rap songs
and modern dance and there was something
about the presentational aspect of that
show that reminds me of alice when she's
presenting
i love that
i can only imagine that a lot of
actresses who might have read the script
as soon as they got to the walking
through the casino lobby scene would
have been like i can't i can't do it and
kristen that was like
made her want to do it which is so
amazing she's so brave that was such a
big deal to shoot that the casino was
open when we shot that
so they had a bunch of tarps and stuff
it was really she's fearless she's truly
fearless oh my god so there were people
who kind of just happened upon it that
happened kind of yeah we were very
concerned that people would take their
phones out but it never happened oh
thank goodness
yeah
there's so many just
bonkers moments in this movie which is
why i love it so much when since you
were on the set for
most or all of the filming what were
some moments where you and shira the
director just looked at each other or
cast members and thought i can't believe
that we're doing this right now kind of
almost every day it was that kind of a
shoot just watching kristen do what she
does is really really really astounding
yeah it was a daily thing at that moment
and and you you're hoping to work with
her again i would love to work with her
again oh my god she's so good she's such
a good actor she's great okay so here's
the last thing if this had been a tv
series instead of a movie
and let's say it had gone
for 13 half-hour episodes what would
have happened
i think alice would become a famous
video artist
and then maybe she represents the u.s
and the venice biennale she becomes an
art star right
why not right why not i i could see a
sequel welcome to us yeah all of us